bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous cela fait plus de deux
semaines que la côte d'ivoire est
maintenant sans premier ministre depuis
donc le décès d'un à dungu coulibaly
comment expliquer cette attente alors il
faut dire que de prison voie tracée
tellement encore dans l'émotion parce
que après le décès de son dos français
qu'il a choisie pour lui succéder
alors elle encore du mal à retrouver
donc toutes ces tâches alors qu'on sait
très bien que le premier ministre en
côte d'ivoire nous sommes dans un régime
présidentiel est le premier nice
partagent donc les effectifs avec le
président à l'exception de toute la
politique gouvernementale et à tous les
grands dossiers
vu que le pays aujourd'hui confrontés à
la pandémie 2009
il ya plusieurs discussions sur la table
notamment au niveau social ou de la
population ne la sentais pas tout est
vraiment à réfère alors vu que le
premier ministre de plus en plus
puisqu'il est décédé le 8 juin dernier
la cote voix c'est au tour d'ophélie de
son chef de gouvernement est sans
compter que d'autres institutions sont
aujourd'hui dans la même situation que
la paix mathieu alors c'est la pause et
évidemment déséquilibre les pas des
indices ou dysfonctionnements alors les
grandes questions en ce moment en côte
d'ivoire c'est de savoir si l'actuel
président alassane ouattara va lui
candidater pour un troisième mandat est
ce que c'est possible sont écoutés et du
moment présent
lui même avait donc plusieurs fois effet
sorti son intention de briguer un
troisième mandat car ce que issue
reviennent ainsi sa décision de désigner
son premier disque en mettant sur le
candidat de son parti politique
alors aujourd'hui que ce dernier n'est
plus c'est vrai que dans son corps un
groupe est en train de pousser à l'a104
à briguer un troisième mandat attention
il ya quand même une constitution
ivoirienne qui a été donc modifié à en
2016 qui dans ses articles notamment la
tête 183 ne permet pas selon donc le
commentaire de certains
constitutionnalistes émis par la
centrale du bugey et troisième mandat
et c'est vrai que il ya toute une
polémique autour de cette constitution
de compans qui pourrait pas non plus 80
dans d'autres notamment ceux qui le
pousse à aller encore guêtres mandat
parce que je suis à l'otan ou à trac
moreno briguer un troisième mandat alors
c'est toute polémique tout un débat il
parce que les jours à venir vont nous
permettre de situer mais à ce que à ce
qui me concerne personnellement il sait
que eux en faisant lecture de cette
nouvelle constitution on se rend bien
compte que c'est vrai on ne sommes dans
une continuité aphatie ce moment le plus
embarrassant pas grave c'est la date
peut être pour tous alors il ya le
retour possible des des anciens on sait
que l'ancien chef de l'état henri
konan-bédié peut-être candidat laurent
gbagbo pourquoi pas ça veut dire que la
classe politique ivoirienne elle a du
mal quand même à se renouveler oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai que en gros on encore
cette pratique en côte d'ivoire c'était
toujours les mêmes qui reviennent à quoi
la tâche politique et le plaisant midi
pesant laurent gbagbo c'est vrai que à
regarder la constitution une aucun
problème il pourrait éventuellement se
présenter
est-ce que la limitation d'âge à 115 ans
a sauté dans la nouvelle constitution
donc pour évidemment oublié donc un
second mandat mais revenant sur le jeu
politique et toutes ces personnalités
ont déclaré en son par kilo est passé le
flambeau à nouvelle génération et alors
ces engagements qui ont été pris par les
invasions ses engagements aujourd'hui
sont pas respectées c'est ce que nous
constatons aujourd'hui pour la jeunesse
ivoirienne serait bien que cette classe
politique soit renouveler totalement
alors pour le souhait de beaucoup c'est
vrai que ce soir on avait dit laurent
gbagbo ou alassane ouattara lui même se
met à l'écart si je pratique que la
prochaine élection soit donc celle qui
va à la génération dû se confronter sur
le terrain et donc audio est vrai lit et
d'evra ellisdon elle et ses membres
alors donc oui allô oui est ce que est
ce qu'il faut craindre une crise
politique justement à la proche de ces
élections et pourquoi pas une crise post
électorale par la suite
écoutez et quand on regarde bien la
situation actuelle il ya évidemment plus
de points d'achoppement est l'opposition
le pouvoir notamment au nouveau la
commission les trois types en marche
fichier électoral et plusieurs points
sont à l'ordre du jour et ces points
n'ont pas arrêté donc réglé évidemment
si on pas dans le contexte actuel
imaginez que plaisant je suis en contact
sa candidature que cette entente est
invalidée par le conseil constitutionnel
si la barre cause évidemment un gros
problème alors dans ce contexte là dans
l'hypothèse qu'elle à se battre à apa
que un troisième mandat aux envies de
soit candidat je ne sais pas de quelle
façon ces promesses a résolu il est
évident que on ne peut pas annuler le
puissant général au soir et cette
élection de temps qu'à octobre
c'est évident merci beaucoup avoue
clément yao je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur du magazine l'afrique
aujourd'hui
merci à vous bonne journée merci